hey everybody what's up welcome to
stream coco
we are very excited today very very
excited we have assist naughty dog
assistant editor jimmy myers with us
today and we are going to be playing
uncharted 4 a thief sand oh goodness
uh very very excited this game it looks
insane uh it's the last one in the
series
it comes out tonight at midnight on the
west coast i know tonight nine pst
and uh midnight on the east coast and
what is it mountain time
you do the math there we go you did the
math it's actually coming out in the
mountains i don't know yeah
um but it's coming out tonight and uh
we're very very excited what's up
everybody good to see you who techgod99
what's up as i don't even know how to
say that name eureka how's it going
disconformity wow that's a lot of woos
this is this might be the most woos per
capita we've ever had in the chat
that's great so we're gonna play today
this is uh very exciting and one of the
cool things jimmy and i were talking
about before uh off camera is this game
is much more sandbox than other
uncharteds yeah the other uncharteds
have been very much on rails but what is
the phrase you used for this one we're
calling it wide linear wide linear i
love that which which is really cool
because i was saying like i get bogged
down in the minutia
of like
collecting flowers and all that stuff
and like there are games i'm not going
to mention them but there are open world
games that i've i love that i've just
stopped playing because
i'm just like i can't it's too much
pressure i can't get out so this is this
is kind of cool because it's all the
best parts of an open world game but
then all the best parts of a game that's
going to tell a great story and be super
exciting like uncharted oh i can't watch
avid gamer no and by the way we should
say right up top we're not going to
spoil anything no no spoilers we're
going to show madagascar which we've
already done our play throughout yes you
haven't seen a playthrough of madagascar
shy away it's shy
maybe audio only yeah maybe
he's podcasted
exactly but otherwise this is not a
scary spoiler territory yes jimmy is not
here to spoil it for you i'm not uh and
i am only here to dance as normal so uh
let's get going so this is we're in
madagascar here uh so go ahead and turn
on the controller it probably turned off
no but it's not okay there we go here we
go
yeah
him and i have the same neck type too i
have to cover mine up with uh
hey you know what never lose his signal
paper
boom
all right this route right here should
take us straight to the volcano
also i love the fact notice this by the
way that gauge yeah really works when
you accelerate oh my god true story now
here's the thing that i love
look at this
well the map shows all these structures
around the volcano
an outpost a handful of watchtowers
watch towers avery was the most wanted
man in the world
so i love this game is absolutely
beautiful
and one of the things that jimmy was
showing me is you can see the tracks in
the dirt which is insane
gas cannon i'm a huge nerd when it comes
to this stuff the gas cane in the back
shifting back and forth is awesome
this is also how i drive in real life in
my real jeep i appreciate you guys
putting uh yeah
just for you yeah you got you got my
text you got my text
uh that's fantastic and and so explain
to the people who who don't know the uh
one percent of people who don't know the
story about nathan drake and uncharted
who are these people what are they doing
right so nathan drake is an explorer
he's a guy who's sort of a thief he
basically looks for old artifacts and
tries to make money off of them and
finds himself in inadvertently in some
pretty dangerous
crazy situations so he's been doing this
for three games now
and we're on the fourth one here uh he's
with sully who is kind of his older wise
kind of uh
ladies man play-esque well except for
the ladies man you know what i'd
definitely see it in the hair here too
uh and then we've got his brother in the
back seat who just re-entered his life
and kind of pulled him into an adventure
for this one
oh uh p.s uh we 2008 thank you jimmy for
your work on an amazing game thank you
it's a jimmy ie or a y it's i.e whoa
there we go
i want to play uncharted forever it's
still too pricey for my budget
dude
by the way i want to say also look at
the wheel this is i'm a huge look at the
mud on the tires
that's dope and when you hit the water
it'll it'll disappear to wash off these
tires i'm just going to spend the whole
game just donuts drive square you can
hit the handbrake oh really yeah here we
go get some speed
hard it's thick mud i will say hold on
let me wash this off
this is great
gorgeous yeah this game is absolutely
gorgeous and like one of the other
things that's really cool is i was
saying before look at the mirrors you
can actually see the reflection of the
dudes in the mirror it's crazy ah got
those tires nice and clean
hey let's go over this waterfall
um so this is the and this is the last
game this is it a thief's end guys it's
not a thief's second to last end which
by the way doesn't really roll off the
tongue either so yeah it's not a thief's
cliffhanger it's not a thief's
cliffhanger
although you will probably hang
there will be cliff hanging
but it will not have hanging exactly and
i love like look at sam wiping his face
off that's awesome and if you watch his
shirts wet now it'll dry off gradually
that's awesome the detail is ridiculous
that this team put together oh the other
thing you were showing me earlier is
check this out we got photo mode which
is great
which is fantastic i wish i could do
this in my real life just imagine how
much easier instagrams would be oh yeah
if you could just stop it freeze time
but yeah this is awesome you can see all
this great stuff that would be the best
use of freezing time instagram taping oh
yeah of course of course the best
application absolutely
absolutely yeah and this is like
absolutely incredible you can wait i
want to go i was looking at what was i
looking at earlier of the mats and the
floor
because i have a jeep so i might outfit
you know it's summertime i got to put
that top down
this is awesome um okay cool there's a
photo there you go
driving skills blows yeah sorry
that's true he drives a real jeep but
it's a little different yeah talk to me
yeah exactly all right so where should i
go here what should we do what's your
call oh i love this this is great
oh let's go up on the bridge it seems
like he's talking about a bridge yeah
this is cool so this is what you're
talking about in terms of wide linear
you get some suggestions
sorry it's rocks
oh i was driving my friend rj's jeep
this weekend and i hit a curb which
wasn't too cool it's not a video game
when you do it in real life and he
doesn't have like this kind of jp no he
has like a nice jeep yeah oh it was kind
of gnarly but you know what you know oh
hey look at this little zen action going
on over here what if i can knock that
over with the give it a try let me just
see
can i pop a tire and replace it with my
spare good question let's hope not oh
there you go oops i hope that wasn't
somebody's like grave like ink engraved
you know what might have been oh there
might be a ghost after you yeah
cursed
that's sweet damn makes me want to get
this game you should get this game comes
out 9 00 p.m tonight on the west coast
midnight east coast
all right i feel like maybe we should go
you can keep it slow
keep it in the center
there's a lot of backseat driving going
on right now
this is awesome the guys who worked on
the dialogue in this are ridiculous how
much dialogue is is there in this like
how many hours they'll tell you hours
but a lot a lot
probably hundreds that's crazy because
you've got these contextual things
you'll go somewhere else in this oh
jesus
also nolan north right yeah illinois
nolan north also appeared uh in the last
of us my favorite games of all time as a
spoiler alert possible cannibal in that
game
possibly not and also uh troy baker who
played the main character is sam oh is
that true oh my god they're back
together wow awesome
that's great
i love it uh weird that nathan drake is
also a cannibal a lot of people don't
know that yeah and you find that out
yeah in real life
in this game you find out he also eats
people what a plot twist
so you've driven a jeep before yeah and
this is fun i've never had luck driving
up uh muddy banks i have not somebody's
realistic
yeah this is true
you know what
i will say also to be a bit of a nerd it
actually feels like i'm drunk oh come on
see what i mean oh man i thought this
actually feels like i'm in the mud
rather than like on top of it exactly
i love also he's telling me what to do
yet i'm not completely ignoring him
he's like go up the rocks nope shut up
sully
uh tishri thank you for not forgetting
troy baker troy baker is amazing you bet
will we be playing multiplayer not today
but we will in future uh stream coco
installments for sure
my shirt says good things great things
happen when you play video games
which is true which is true
it's a very true shirt
all right fine i can give you a hit i
just want to get i just want to get sam
as dirty as possible because he's my
this is how i hate my brother try uh try
hitting some rocks things you can get
some traction
it's kind of fun too like okay because
this is actually what would happen like
that i like that the dialogue isn't
doesn't just all serve the plot
i mean you guys also recorded stuff that
um
like this is how people really would be
if you're trying to get up a money thing
and that's what's oh
that's
exactly my point
exactly my point so almost anywhere you
go there's contextual dialogue that will
happen and you'll have these kind of
organic conversations oh that's awesome
yeah the guys that programmed all this
stuff are just geniuses that's awesome
oh wait now we're on top of this
waterfall i think we saw it
which you can drive off of if you feel
like i mean i'm not i'm not gonna should
we give it a shot do in real life in
your real jeep right should we give it a
shot i'm nervous
are we gonna die off and then time it
with a photo mode oh that's a great idea
kind of like an epic
free death shot i feel like you've done
this before i might have done this
before here we go ready
i'm a little nervous i'd be nervous
buckle up guys buckle up no one's
wearing a seatbelt don't look ready
these guys adventurers do not look ready
all right here we go
i'm actually nervous
all right both sticks oh oh oh but i got
it here shot death shot you can't move
in oh no all right we gotta do it before
you die
right back to the waterfall
is my insurance going to cover that
thomas louise somebody said
exactly exactly that's what we're going
for here
what's the male version of thelma
thelmer
velmer and lewis felmer fun felmer and
lewis
here we go no one wears seat belt says
wither jack here we go
[Music]
all right hit it
yes oh there we go yes look at that
they're pretty comfortable they're all
just like very chill they're not they're
just not talking they're just not
talking to me they're just pondering
life dude you gotta do this again you
gotta why do you do that what are you
doing to me all right give him a little
bit of dutch you want to get ready it's
so pe look at look at how passive
aggressive they are yeah they're like
sally is definitely holding him he's
like yeah i'm disgusted
and he's just like
look at photo finish he's just
he's just like looking off into the
distance like yep someone said this is
their splash mountain photos
this is an amazing place
this is an amazing splash mountain photo
all right i think we're gonna die ready
it was nice knowing you
and
oh that woman was even oh that was came
off
[Music]
oh console peasants in their photo modes
oh pc i love the pc ears
bring it
i walk away for one minute to come back
to this sorry chili fowl you knew this
was going to happen
all right
oh no am i going to break another one of
these do it dude
sorry ghosts
[Music]
bicker mode on i did turn bicker mode on
guys he doubled the price he would have
doubled it anyway
let me go through this whole goddamn
thing and never use that
this is amazing
unluckiest flume ride ever since yeah no
kidding
that's right i know i feel like oh here
we can get up here oh yeah tire tracks
this is cool yeah there's contextual
little hints
contextual i do like too how sam is like
bouncing around in the back oh geez
take this slow kid yeah how about don't
tell me how to live sully
how about that it's kind of a curmudgeon
that's right guys also jimmy is
answering questions i should mention
jimmy's also answering your uncharted
questions if you'd like as well oh yeah
i can sorry about that i just got i got
too obsessed with driving this jeep
and trying to piss my brother off
only death so far we'll have a death
count don't worry
extract says these uh graphics are
amazing yes that's true more a's though
and amazing i think
like i think it's a this is like a an
eight or nine a amazing
don't go back on z's either don't hold
back
you could throw a couple extra ends in
there
oh someone was asking do you need to uh
play previous games to understand the
plot not necessarily um but it is better
there are definitely some inside jokes
and relationships that are fleshed out
oh nice we do have the nathan drake
collection on ps4 that has all three in
hd so it's a great experience
but i would say you could do that after
you beat this as well you shouldn't let
it hold you back oh that's interesting
and i love that and go and no
man
gee there's a lot of dialogue in this
game it's awesome all right let's get
out i feel like we're gonna like right
now to walk up here
it's in pretty good shape for something
several hundred years old yeah it's just
definitely ruins from avery's era
gotta
nathan drake has got to be in pretty
good shape he's a good child what do you
think his workout regimen is he's
probably doing a lot of uh have one it's
just parkour yeah it's probably finding
treasure yeah
he just lifts treasure with each hand
exactly it's just gold
exactly here we go i don't actually know
the controls but it's pretty intuitive
ooh what's this look it's christopher
condon sizzle is the captain of the
fiery dragon operated out of madagascar
around avery's time all right let's not
show off here sam recruits pirate
captains
that'd be his lookouts i'm just going to
write a quick note in my opinion
well maybe each captain was responsible
for a tower along with providing them in
front
whatever the case
this certainly isn't our final stop on
our tour
so just to give you some context they
are following the trail of henry avery a
famous pirate okay and trying to find
this kind of legendary treasure that he
stole
it was kind of his biggest um theft in
his pirate career got it and they're
trying to find it so they're in
madagascar following these guard towers
that he had in place to try to hide from
authorities nice
i like it
man this is cool check that out
and you can find you can
figure out a lot of this from the uh
pixar film madagascar i think also
yeah the cartoons showed up they show up
later in this game
uh to answer dela ii
uh it's the sony engine it's a
proprietary engine that they use at
naughty dog oh that's awesome
is this the same engine that was used in
the last of us
i don't know that i actually don't know
the name of the engine interesting um
i'm an editor so
but you should ask the naughty dog
twitter account maybe they'll be able to
answer you it is weird how nathan drake
and i look exactly yeah that's weird
right so just amazingly handsome it's
their oh yeah it's our own engine
uh
yeah how do you think like nathan drake
and lara croft would they get together
or not what do you think they're two
independent people they're two rogues
they're two lone wolves they're like two
negative magnets yeah although i would i
would like to see like a dinner between
them too just one-upping each other you
know and then probably end with uh it
probably honestly it'd probably be like
the brad pitt what's that movie mr mrs
smith that's true yeah yeah it'd
probably be very and she played lara
croft anyway so
all right let's see here let's explore
let's walk around oh god
oh thank god oh man he's way
way better he knew i was going to do
that the cliff count and death count
that was your cliff yeah that's number
two that's number two
i would definitely ship nathan drake
uh to answer the question about how long
we've worked on it it's been in
production for four years yeah
they wouldn't do the same yeah crossover
all right let's let's see here how do we
get up i feel like
try to get up top there
let's walk around over
here one
i don't know if this is a real question
but someone is asking if crash bandicoot
is hidden in the game crash [ __ ]
i have crashed the jeep several times we
crashed it like a bandicoot like yeah
like a bandicoot like when we're driving
exactly oh here so we should hook the
winch up to this movie you got it you've
got a puzzle mind here we go man let's
see
and by the way if you're extremely
stupid like me this game is uh it is you
can figure things out
[Music]
dr jeff it fluctuates in size dr jeff
just asked how big the naughty dog team
is um
it was up to i think 320 at the end of
this game
this is oh again this is ridiculous but
awesome check this look at his hand as
he goes down
oh wait he did it before now he's going
to do it
oh yeah look at this yeah he kind of
just like if you just sit still he's got
a whole bunch of sort of nervous ticks
that he does too just like me
looking around exactly looks around
his fingernails he loses his nose he
kind of messes with his fingers there
you go oh yeah look what you said yeah
bruh clouds are moving clouds aren't
moving oh yeah and the shadows actually
get cast on the ground from the clouds
really
jesus lord in heaven above amen oh my
gosh jump in the mudslide from the top
all right you definitely should do that
fair enough
i am your puppet internet watch the rut
that you leave in the mud
awesome it's a butt rod
[Music]
see can we climb up you can
this is great
[Laughter]
an rl simulator oh yeah how much time do
you guys spend on the single player
computer so what is the multiplayer in
this game what if the multiplayer has a
bunch of different modes and it's
awesome all on its own um but it's got
team death match it's got a mode called
plunder where you have a big idol and
you have to run it to a treasure chest
and you kind of play tug of war with two
teams to try to get the idol into it oh
that's cool that's awesome but yeah
that's a whole separate thing it's
awesome
how can we let's figure out a way up
here i love his falling down
i just want to do this
[Laughter]
people like show us more in this game
and i'm like
someone was asking for a hill flip count
there you go oh man
wow
yeah the benny hill theme i know i was
gonna say yeah you need a benny hill
mode okay so maybe try this yeah maybe
we'll try the stairs although was having
it was having a great time
i do i will slide back down so there
will be how can anybody watch this sorry
man
[Laughter]
so here's a little fun physics
detail you actually have to circle the
tree that's crazy right very fun and
then hook it up
that's great this is also teaching you
how to put a winch on a tree right yeah
it's teaching you practice
here's another fun thing you can enter
the jeep from almost anywhere oh really
give this a try jump up on the stairs
and then jump onto the jeep whoa all
right get a little flashy
oh man this is something i would never
do in real life because i'm afraid of
hurting myself you should maybe consider
sarah in the back
i know when it makes sarah laugh i gotta
get i got a good check all right go for
it
good oh nice triangle
there you go
dude how cool is he ready give it a shot
that's great
ready hello obvious doc king 2k14
that's crazily realistic that's awesome
yeah
see sully
witch totally worried we clearly
i think there was death i mean there's
somebody's asking if there was a uh
indiana jones uh inspiration for nathan
drake i mean i think you have to i mean
you have to yeah you have to you have to
what do you of course
weren't we all inspired by indiana jones
absolutely
um
but it seems to me too like the cool
thing about uncharted
is it feels like it's taking indiana
jones to like the next level which is
really cool because again like you can
do stuff in video games you just can't
do in the movies a well-to-do pirate far
away from your oppressive government
also i like the fact too that nathan
drake is kind i mean he is also a th
he's stealing things like indiana jones
is always like it belongs in a museum
right right banana is like it also kind
of belongs in the old wallets that's it
so
so this is kind of what you're talking
about in terms of wide linear now we're
like in another area that we can explore
exactly
um but it's sort of funneling you right
yeah yeah yeah we have the freedom of
movement around but
this is literally how most cheap drivers
drive
as my mom would attest that is correct
oh wait now i just i have to knock all
those over yeah you have to i gotta jump
out of the jeep and punch it oh that's a
great idea i like where your head's at
jimmy
mine meld i like where your head's at
she's gonna have to get a photo mode mid
punch yeah
oh
sweet shoot it too if you want wait how
do i punch square here we go
close to it that's what i like to do is
punch rocks
this also teaches you words like cairn
oh those are called cairns there we go
you know
hmm i guys i just don't care
thank you i saw that one comic genius
boom oh man he can't even open the door
that's that ass that's he's such a
badass look at this
look at that that's a good by the way
great from every angle great try it on
the other side great vertical leap this
is like a show-and-tell for the
animation team on this one try it from
here his
oh
wow power move by the way eight
animations together power move on sully
how emasculating is this for selling
this is like that fight club scene yeah
yeah exactly oh
[Laughter]
he's lost his mind
i'm just parkouring the hell out of this
oh there we go i was trying to do it in
front of his brother's face
let me just do it
oh yeah hide your girl hide your wife
sully's getting an eyeful says
i am remarkably flexible for those tight
pants yeah i will say they're stretchy
they are safe they are stretching
probably ten percent
that's right h m
yeah exactly
what's this this looks like something
over here
someone said fun charted yeah exactly
what this is
uncharted
jesus play the game mate sorry i'm sorry
now
is it nabal or nabil you tell me
what about the front we already did the
front
oh yeah let's just get going you know
guys i'm not a terrible driver i just
want you to know look at these moves
[Music]
oh yeah see now we're getting into it
eight and a half more hours until i
could get in and out of a jeep for 20
minutes
exactly oh should we try going in here
we could try it let's give it a shot
this is another one of our wives
hold on wait a second i want to make
sure i get out the right way
there we go in your face sam
let's see here
nope nothing stay in the jeep
whoa got yourself a treasure hey that's
the ugliest pokemon i've ever seen in my
life
that's awesome
now see it's too bad there's no cell
reception here because this is a good
gram it's good this is a good question
that's what photo you know what i'm
saying this would be a good little
selfie
oh too many uh that's the debug oh
perfect
oh god
look at this look at that that's a good
jawline you know what i'm saying all
right
this is this game is gonna horribly play
into my vanity
gotta buy them gotta buy them all
ugliest pokemon pokemon count creative
corner wants a pokemon count
yeah there's so many counts no forget it
no pokemon pokemon counts at one yeah
you know we'll just we'll just
keep it in our heads the pokemon count
there is another cairn to kill but maybe
maybe leave this one yeah we need no one
let's go this way
oh boy
nope it's fedex
they're just delivering some packages
good news
cam this game comes out uh 9 uh pst
tonight and midnight on the east coast
true true
so here's the thing this is a combat
encounter you can come at it any way you
want okay you can go totally guns
blazing or you can sneak there's a lot
well i'm going straight in at first
let's do it let's do it get him get him
get him you're a jeep driver
get him oh we got one of them we got one
we're going back we're going oh don't
shoot at the gas can oh that's bad
that's bad get this guy i missed him oh
god nope nope back over oh well that gun
went flying
now we're just applying all right no
worries i'm gonna
no where's the other guy laser sight
that's cheating cheating
oh yeah oh my god i love stamps just
and you're dead
[Applause]
okay
super dead let's try it again
all right let's try it
i feel like maybe going in might not be
the baby they're about to come down with
a bad case of explosions yeah that's
true oops just want to make sure that
you're here just want to make sure that
you're oh jesus what i'm going in i'm
going in
this is gonna work no come on all right
let's go find some cover no he's like
oh
do some invasion
all right yep
kill this guy you're dead
now you can go hide and regain your
health oh god oh good that's good yeah
right here hit circle
yeah now you're in cover
yep
i feel like this is this is just a bad
this is not gonna go well it might i
have faith in
you pick them off one at a time avoid
the lasers that's a sniper
why can't i get lasers
[Music]
oh god this is such a mistake
this is the biggest oh this is such a
mistake try square there you go
oh hello
yo
square square oh oh
oh dude i'm dead wow i'm great at
hand-to-hand combat though those are
some great moves
that was awesome
kill this number shirt all right now
let's we're actually going to be quiet
did you climb the side of the tower and
take down the sniper first there you go
is that two assassins what's up no it's
perfect you could try this grass here
kind of sneak into the side see where it
gets you all right here we go
do a quick roll just so i look cool that
wasn't for any that was just so i look
cool oh that was more than possible you
know before you attack a sniper tower
you got to get your confidence up you
got to go you want to look good you want
to feel good you know practice how you
play et cetera et cetera
okay i love these bushes by the way
it's like hey where's it
god damn it i dropped my phone where's
it
son of a
all right here we go
all right fellas
is there a crouch what am i doing if you
get into the grass you crouch so it's
got to be tall grass though okay good
i'll just do it naturally that's good
okay all right
let's pick these dudes off first of all
let's not shoot at the ground so there's
another feature that just got added in
this game by the way oh really aim at
someone
and then you click on l3
you can mark them there you go oh here
we go
so then you can tell kind of in your
peripheral vision where they're at oh
this is great
i have to say like i'm not a big fan of
like you have a camera and you need to
pull out your camera this is really cool
because i don't carry cameras around
when i'm attacking sniper towers dude
let's get this guy
there we go
oh
mark and oh my god oh my god yeah
there's a little army you got
moses okay don't get overwhelmed all
right
oh two more dudes over there come on
how are they paying all these guys uh i
hope they're getting their w-2s out on
time
that's important
it's probably 1099s in this case yeah
you know you're independent contractors
very smart very smart all right let's
i'm just going to try to sneak around
totally
nathan drake doesn't have allergies does
he because theirs looks like there's a
lot of pollen here maybe almonds okay
i've never seen him encounter an almond
that's just the one thing
dude the idol is surrounded by almonds
no o'malley's got a nut allergy he knows
what i'm talking about he's a bushes for
cover yeah uh oh spoon asked jimmy did
naughty dog know what game they plan to
work on next oh it's unannounced at this
time unannounced
um but it's i think it's uncharted 5 the
aaron blair story it's just me crying
alone in my apartment it's a q it's a
mobile game
it's kind of like flappy bird i would
buy that it's a lot like flappy bird you
just press the buttons to keep from
driving to pits
i should sneak attack and take out the
enemies quietly thanks reptar mom i
think what do you think that this is
reptile mom knows what's up prepped our
mom reptar
nom sorry
he like eats reptiles
pass me the controller says yeah
okay here we go if you do want kind of a
pro play through i i could step on
quit oh no oh don't worry you're
definitely gonna have to step in here
this is just another way for me to get
murdered but now here's the issue
the guys are all around the tower
you know all right let's hear i think
i'm gonna take this dude out over here
first that's a great strategy okay here
we go
luckily i'm wearing earth tones so i
blend in
just in like like under armour like
you're like orange spandex there is
actually a bonus mode once you beat the
game you can put on most costumes in the
game really oh absolutely
that's great and you can play through as
oh that's awesome just like in attack
just go in and kill those bastards
all right
uh every shot looks like a painting it
does this is gorgeous
okay oh man oh
this is the part i hate i hate i hate
right before i have to go in
all right here we go
i'm just going in i'm just going in do
we think this guy's looking at you
do we think we sneak or do we think we
just run oh when that guy turns around
i'm running
yeah this is your guy
is there like a can i sneak up behind
somebody and yeah okay totally
now that'd just be square bullets you do
yeah
but you get bullets from
people once you've killed them so oh
yeah
so try climbing up right there there you
go
to the left perfect jumped right in
place like i wanted to perfect now
you'll also notice that sam and sully
are a huge help in this one yeah
fighting by the way can the guys see sam
and sully or no like will will they
they can but not a little bit
okay they can't really just like ruin it
for you okay good yeah
so go ahead and jump up there give it a
try
there you go and now if you wait for
this guy hit square
now you've got a sniper rifle if you
wanted oh if i want it i don't know i'm
open minded you know what
nah i don't need this sniper rifle so
now hit circle circle there you go
getting cover
all right if you switch the sniper rifle
with right on the stick i mean on the uh
oh got it okay so the d-pad is our
weapon
all right where's this sob
good thing we marked those guys let's
see maybe we take him off from the top
but i don't know if i can see that guy
all right michael swe yes half-life 3 is
confirmed
perfect
nice yes shoot all the mofos all right
that's a good strategy yeah solid
oh
right in the face
oh jesus
oh no no no
all right but it did bring that you know
what it did do though brought the sniper
out here
nice pop pop pop
oh oh awesome this is taking on like
three guys
can can he die can they die i'll be
perfect
oh in the butt i like to shoot him in
the butt whenever he just took him out
but also oh man you did great
there's a grenade oh jesus no
it only hurt you a little bit
so here's another functionality that you
haven't seen yet this rope oh and you
hit l1 it's the top shoulder button all
right you'll swing on the rope there you
go oh yeah oh man i look cool
if you do that and someone's under you
hit square and you'll punch them let's
go
punch them
where are they
[Music]
oh god oh god
yeah i know bro i'm feeling you
let's get up yeah let's get up there
let's get up there
there's a guy punch
30 foot fall the dude's not gonna
survive
oh man
oh no dude dude
is that sam yeah
[Music]
all the guys are in the tower
oh there he is
jesus
oh god oh god yeah there you go god
i'm backseat driving oh he's held him
before you hit him
oh
tag team
oh i will pick this up thank you
did we get him you got him oh man that
was done
i love this move by the way
that's so awesome
that was awesome all right
i love by the way the choreography is
great on the fights
that's really cool
i totally be shooting sam all the time
well oh read by nature as well there'll
be co-op modes in multiplayer there well
yeah oh it's confirmed that's um it's
not out yet at launch we have the three
main modes uh and then co-op is going to
be coming if you look at the official
playstation blog uh there's a chart that
shows you when everything's coming out i
think co-op is coming out in a few
months or maybe six months
on excavation by explosions i think i
want that sniper rifle
i just want to use the rope again
i'm all about that rope
somebody said this is dude raider
that's awesome
dude raider
yeah i think i left the sniper rifle
where is it
uh
you know the place is riddled with
bodies and guns yeah
it's just like
chaos oh yeah this is a great photo by
the way oh you know what i think the
sniper rifle is over here another trick
uh this is a secret insider trick ooh
if you get a grenade
throw it on the ground and then jump off
of something and go into photo mode oh
really wait hold on wait let's try let
me try it wait do these explode those
explode all right you can get even
bigger explosion go pick up a grenade
there was one right back there i think i
i might have one wait i don't think you
do how do i switch oh yeah you do you do
so it's r1 don't press it yet okay uh
you'll hold it and it'll give you a
little arc okay and you'll drop it okay
i'll then just jump and hit photo mode
this is gonna take totally gonna die
it's a combo you might as well just say
kill yourself immediately please kill
yourself this is just four times in the
future
exactly so so drop the grenade by these
barrels oh my sniper rifle fell off my
back in the upper level first of all i
just want to try this thing i'm gonna
kill myself real quick all right hold on
okay so i'm going to drop okay l1
grenade run this way we're going to run
jump and then l3 and r3 at the same time
okay drop a grenade
right away run and jump run and jump
oh
let's see if there's an explosion behind
you still nope
close though but i also didn't kill
myself you didn't which is good way to
go that's pretty great look at this
or wait did no no i'm just very close oh
look at that one-handed mm-hmm he's got
great forearm strength i told you he
doesn't oh you can also swing oh this is
cool but you can also get your um
you can shoot from there too oh really
yeah try it out oh dude
ya boy
wait hold on this is going to be a cool
shot
oh almost
almost
i can't even look cool i can't
how cool is this dude and i can't i i'm
awkward even with naked
i've found i can make anything look
awkward you're channeling yourself
yeah exactly
that's right unfortunately i'm still
myself playing this game
exactly
all right
[Laughter]
uh jimmy is the unannounced game the
last of us too jimmy's just like
actually it's the last of us three
they're skipped they're skipping the
last of us too they're just gonna go
straight to three it's called uh really
the last of us really this time
the absolute really last of us
um i did really like the
expansion was cool the dlc for the last
of us was really fun yeah
uh it was great heartbreaking of course
i wept naturally like you do
yeah we talked about this okay yo yeah
oh a lot of the last of us and you
didn't weep yeah you're not i don't get
you yeah yeah you're not a human being
i do like this and by the way this is a
feature i wish they had in real life
with my real jeep find your car
exactly cheap if you're paying attention
take what they're doing in this game and
make it a reality
i haven't been uh this excited about it
video games since uncharted 2. there we
go baby a lot of the reviews are saying
they like it better that's right
uncharted 2 one of the greatest games of
all time yeah ranked extremely like
number three i think in all time games
yeah the last one a ciggy oh yeah there
is old salty sack there is
i'm just going with it bud go with it uh
there is aim assist there are a whole
slew of options to help any kind of
disabled gamers where you have one stick
support you have aim assist there's a
ton of stuff that can help almost
anybody even with like disabilities to
be able to play the game
squad goals everybody jumps everywhere
at once that's great but yeah you have
camera assist when you're in cover
there's a whole slew of stuff so you can
make it as supportive as you want for
like um any kind of disability it's
great that's right sure kill uh can i
jump into hay from high places in this
game yeah you
can
it's so beautiful that's right jc
this game is
awesome
this is definitely like i was just
saying before we were starting i've seen
one of my favorite games is red dead
redemption because it is so beautiful
and i just would like ride around and
this is this i can definitely see myself
doing the same thing in this game just
like literally just driving around
because it's so awesome oh let's see
let's get up on this bridge
let's get up on that brian you know
bridge life that's true doing it
i you know this game is telling me i
need to go off-road i'm like gee gee no
it's not this game is telling me not to
go off-road on my jeep i said that at
exactly the wrong time
that's exactly what i'm afraid of
happening with my real jeep you know how
much money that was you shouldn't drive
on wooden bridges
this is a rental so i think we're good
there does happen to be a winch on this
by the way here we go
oh wait i don't want to get back in the
thing
can you command characters to do their
act do actions or they do their own
thing they do their own thing which is
helpful because i'm terrible at
commanding people to do things
i just end up doing it all by myself and
the guys then just end up like
like doing that weird
standing around but it was awesome like
having sam like yeah we're seeing like
and then he's just like it's really
awesome when it works out super well too
like you're sneaking up on somebody and
then somebody right next to you grabs
them it's totally yeah that was dope
like sam had him and i just yeah that
was great
squad goals uh all right here we go
let's grab the switch
now this is something that a lot of
people actually asked about when they
saw this you can do one at a time oh but
you can also do first of all this looks
like it could come up
oh let's do both then let's do both oh
this is great
uh
place to be two uh yes i absolutely do
intend to finish this game not on this
stream today right now
but on my own twitch stream for sure
this is the next game i'm gonna
play forever um
because it's awesome but i might start
jimmy was saying though i should maybe
start
with the first uncharted yeah to get the
best uh to get the complete the complete
story story i recommend it
exactly
uh oh mdf7 uh yeah glad they made it
more dynamic with four absolutely hold
on i like to do the quick thing where i
show sully my butt mm-hmm let's get that
butt mount boom
he's just like and i love he's just like
come on he's he's
traction
[Music]
keep going
ah
[Music]
yeah and by the way i did do both
pillars as you saw that's just showing
off the physics you can you can wrap it
around both you can just wrap it
physically around one and you still pull
on it it works like a real cable there
we go man this jeep can take a beating
i'll say that
oh
sorry
all right sam's writing him back i'm
surprised sam hasn't thrown up yet
frankly he's got a strong stomach uh
slayer darth
a lot of times
the trailers are like the parts of the
game that are ready so they're still the
real game but it'll be things that we
know are polished that we can show
and so the first trailer will usually be
those sections it takes a lot of
coordination with the team to get that
but yeah it's all
the real game
and i should probably shout out joe
patnati and i uh worked on that first
trailer if you saw it oh cool joe
patnati is the uh video editor at
naughty dog awesome he's awesome and
he's at home right now with a new baby
ooh congratulations
joe
what's his last name
pat notty
weird that he named his kid nathan drake
patnati yeah but i guess that's just
yeah that's why i have to name my child
conan o'brien blair
but you know conan o'brien uh o'brien is
not a terrible middle name
damn thing but they found the treasure
already oh uh
jimmy what was your role in the dev
station
i am the assistant editor so i worked on
a lot of marketing materials a lot of
the
trailers that you saw i helped make
a lot of the screenshots that you saw i
took and i also worked with
ryan james who's our lead cinematics
editor
and worked on the
cinematics in the game so
editing motion capture footage
audio that sort of thing
especially anything related nick at
night did you guys use technologies in
this game this game has many
technologies several yeah several times
i think there's about five or six
technologies
wait somebody wanted to see me drive and
bail can i drive in bailey
you know actually there's a pretty cool
little trick
if you want to go i love it when you say
there's a brute pretty cool little trick
surprising go back it leads me to be
to kill myself in a spectacular fashion
go back to uh where you came from where
the rope was oh sure
by the tower because the wardens saw it
go back to the tower down the bridge
yeah oh don't see since it's wide linear
we can do that oh wait hold on one
second
just got it's got to go
that's how i take out my aggressions had
it coming
nathan's like no no i'm fine i'm fine
just punching rocks somebody's daring
you to drift
oh i'll drift i'm gonna fast and furious
for tokyo drift or faster furious three
tokyo drift up in this uh anyway all
right let's see
see where was that back to the left i
actually don't remember you know come to
think of it i actually dealt with
alcazar
seven rock punch count you know i think
there will be one ahead let's keep going
we'll find one oh i do remember driving
by this though
this thing
i love this is actually how it would be
we would be lost
this is i'm pretty sure you are too real
this is so realistic
explodes
provocation
really hasn't changed much then has he
i got my money there will be another
rope all right so just keep going you
promised me more reps it's either this
is the way back it's back this way if
you want to go back
all right all right fire walks into it
yes this will be coming out as uncharted
64 on n64 people think that they don't
still make n64 games but they do
underground you know what i do i
actually do really love i think they did
do an uncharted like a fake nintendo 8
did you see that thing where they made a
bunch of games that were like side
scrolling yeah besides the end yeah as
if they had done as if this had come out
in a different era
i love that stuff
so there are some animals i saw somebody
mention
uh
that they didn't see any animals and
there were some oh yeah no birds and
there's a bunch of like lemurs there are
lemurs yeah those are the hit and
there's an eagle oh yeah oh there we go
another dive bomb
i mean now we're in a giant loud jeep so
there's not going to be a lot of animals
because they'll be scared freaked out
but there are oxen or something
yeah there you go there's some over
there
did you guys like send people to
madagascar yeah that's crazy that's what
that's the job i want i need to go do
research
exactly kill yourself now tyrion
lannister a uh never trusted never trust
atlantis or b they do always pay their
debts
worth checking out
yeah
i'm just not like i'm in this for a
treasure or anything wait where's the
old building oh here we go
this is awesome
oh yeah you know what someone was saying
wait in oh we're on a safari now this is
yeah there go the animals those were
some lemurs and like a sheep or
something wait i do want to see you were
saying something about photo filters
someone was asking about photo filters
go through that in the um
go toward a cliff yeah let's get a cool
stuff yeah there we go there we go
want a job with naughty dog
that's right great crusader we're not
far in the game this is the beginning of
the game this is yeah this is probably
a little ways into the game but not even
halfway watch this move oh crap oh wait
are you going to go full suicide freeze
frame it's going to do a little filming
oh that's good filmer louise oh it's not
that far down all right i wonder if i
could do this
definitely die all right
yay animals says somebody
does the car get destroyed and you crash
yeah we flipped over
yeah the wheels all fly off
there's actually a surprising amount of
detail on the bottom of the jeep because
they knew you would be flying is that
true that's true
they call that blade detail but just do
it when you get like an idiot
i love it we're gonna be playing for
about another half hour today by the way
if you're just joining us we're here
with the uh naughty dog uh assistant
editor jimmy myers he is answering our
questions about uncharted 4 today the
game comes out tonight at midnight on
the east coast nine pacific time and in
the mountains uh uh check your location
your own math yeah check it out do your
own math
um all right so here we go wait what's
going to do yeah so show me some of
these filters wait so how do we all
right so yeah check this out get it get
it framed the way you like it all right
you know what i like i i'm gonna go do
you like dutch angles i'm gonna go in a
little bit
i'm gonna go see they're kind of like
i'll look at it nathan he's telling him
like about like oh man i tell you this
one story when i was that's true there's
a koi look on sam's face right now yeah
it's so coy
all right
so try giving a little dutch push left
on the cross pad left on the cross
oh this is great a little bit of art
there you go
this is afternoon this is afternoon and
drinking
this is actually dope this is going to
be the cover to our um
our 90s boy bear 90s boy made out yeah
that's it
all right so now press up
this is great wait can how far can i go
ah
oh i could go all the way around this is
actually
music video this is so dutch this is
when they don't like this is two dots
this is too dutch all right this is good
all right that's pretty good i like that
so press up on the d-pad
and you can go through some other stuff
this will let you hide everybody in case
you want to oh this is cool it's pretty
cool oh wow this is awesome this is uh
if i just want to get a product shop
yeah it's just a product shop for your
jeep that was inspired by you this is
crazy uh go up one more after you bring
them back we need them in there
this is so cool
that's man you guys thought of
everything
all right great all right let's have
everybody get it i'd feel bad all right
go up
so this is your saturation it's any kind
of like photo filters you would think of
you can whoa whoa
yeah oh this is from the martian yeah
we're going 90s still here
this is like the uh the drug flashback
shot this is every time i get killed
this is very breaking bad-esque
it
is this is so cool so go up one more
this is chromatic aberrations what is
the chromatic have you ever shot oh look
at this plastic lens
color uh separation oh my god this is
awesome that's crazy
yeah let's go uh hold on i'm gonna go
back down to saturation saturated oh
yeah yeah this is your like train
spotting shot right yeah exactly this is
from my holga this is a great ad for
road hog
by the way yeah by the way this is also
uh mostly an ad for winches yeah this is
so weird
this is crazy oh motion blur oh yeah so
there's motion blur if you're doing
something like jumping you'll see it
really pronounced okay if you're sitting
still you won't see it so much okay cool
we'll take the motion blur down
uh you can sharpen it to make it look a
little bit more punchy oh yeah right
yeah
or soften it this is great this is
glaucoma the glaucoma filter
perfect brighten it up oh this is
awesome
and you guys had a little bit of this in
the last of us too
yeah yeah yeah which is really cool i
remember taking some photos of giraffes
just weeping mm-hmm i was weeping not
the giraffes somebody can just spend
hours in this thing getting these
amazing shots oh i do somebody uh i'm
not gonna name any names buddy his
initials are aaron blair
those are your initials yeah yeah it's
an
acronym i was created you're going to
laugh crazy yeah oh this is good i have
been by the way accused in instagram of
uh vignetting too much
so this is for all you haters just just
go for it look at that maximum vignette
we're at maximum vignette yeah this is
great
this is great oh my god this is diff
oh perfect names whoa dope yeah you can
go oh that's cool this is great
cinematic
oh awesome
whoa this is like a disneyland yeah if
we take
this is for the uncharted ride it does
exactly yeah this is for oh we should
have used this for a splash mountain
shop
oh my god ah next time next time whoa
this is crazy yeah i love this and that
was the naughty dog oh there's right
there
boom
jump off the cliff i'm addicted to this
photo mode
all right so keep going keep going we're
going to get to the filters here are the
filters oh no so this is all of the
stuff they were asking about oh this is
great everybody's asking what nathan
drake's instagram is yeah that's a great
question you know what you know i don't
follow him absolutely that is why he
just mostly posts pictures of food i
don't vignette enough oh thank you
that's very nice of you to say yeah
oh this is awesome
this is like guys always remember boys
night out
this is killer man
so what's fun too is when you beat the
game you can unlock some of these looks
or the whole game so the whole game will
look like this
oh my god that's pretty cool wow that's
awesome i guess somebody said uh we've
been in i spent some time doing this
with the hd collections photo mode
yeah exactly
wow this is awesome destagram
i feel the view oh my gosh you can zoom
in zoom out
and then if you go back you can change
the focus so that you're focusing on
them or past them whatever you want
it's very ken burns-ass
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah they feel like they're
out of focus right now but if you go
here and you hit distance yeah there you
go pull them out oh yeah look at that
there you go oh wow crazy
this is awesome
wow my god
yes please
wow that was fantastic
instagram get on your game i need some
of that stuff in real in real life
there's a few questions about what the
co-op
modes are gonna be uh that hasn't been
discussed yet um that's something that
the playstation blog covers uh
officially right now and i think you can
probably hit up robert cogburn or
naughty dog's twitter for any more
details uh photo rogers of four whose
idea was it a naughty dive for photo
mode they're a genius i'm actually not
sure that's cool
i know somebody there's a there's a
great story that i don't know all of
where somebody just pulled an
all-nighter and implemented it and last
of us remastered whoa
they were like we need photo mode in
this and somebody just stayed up all
night put it in patched it and it was
out well done yeah all right somebody
wants to see me drive off the cliff i
got to do it i'm sorry sorry everybody
just got to happen i'm going to bail can
i bail maybe hit triangle
oh i did right at the end
right at the end
oh man i all right i should have hold on
let me just try that one more time show
12 is looking for realism yeah you don't
have to eat or drink even though this
does feel very realistic yeah exactly i
know bathroom breaks and probably while
you're playing you won't eat or drink
you don't need to check the the tire
pressure at any point it's fine all
right oh there you go we're going to do
a little total film in louisiana this is
this is amazing this is amazing all
right wait hold on we're going to back
it up wait we're going to huh let's get
below it i want to i've got all these uh
i know one let's bring down the
saturation it's at 107 what am i doing
with my light oh god
come on here we go
hold on
nate and the boys on the way to
coachella
beach house is going to be so dope all
right this is what we want oh yeah here
we go
motion blur
that is a great shot so then hide the ui
that is a great shot and there's the
show dude wait i want to put the splash
mountain thing on it though
oh yeah you got to put some i got it
wait hold on where's the frame
yeah let's let's film graeme it up film
grain it up a little bit
reptar nom they are calm they're used to
this they've driven off this cliff a
thousand times yeah especially when i'm
playing
this is uh just oh look at that there's
our splash mount
that's it that's perfect
oh my god it's my favorite
the ultimate would be the dukes of
hazzard voiceover
i know
i love it and
all right
this is yeah this is a selfie simulator
i told you guys this is going to be a
vain stream
all right sorry all right let's keep
playing
these guys are way too confident in
nathan's driving skills all poker faces
or they're just like resigned to the
fact that he's just gonna hit stuff
all right here we go i feel like we want
to get up towards that black smoke oh
there's some animals
there are the lemurs running up
there's some eagles there's the wildlife
yes there will be aim assist yes for
those who yeah there is yeah and also
there will be a co-op mode coming on not
at launch right but not at launch but
later and it's multiplayer co-op
oh that's awesome
all right let's see
well
get it get it you know because
it's a well
i get it
i love that shadow
when do we see the animated madagascar
characters already made that joke the
lemurs just ran away from us exactly
yeah
the penguins are staying away tlc let's
see what should we do here you could
just jump in should i shoot it someone
said to drive into the well okay
what's that someone said to drive drive
i mean
i'll try
you know guys you know i love driving
let's see oh it actually might fit
guys just oh i got that look at sam he's
like no
he's like dude i got this guys don't
worry
yep you don't you know what i got it i
got everyone
all right getting out over sully all
right here we go
getting in over sully okay i'm gonna
jump down there
oh boom oh here we go mysterious well
why are we here
whoa
i love the hand on the wall
punch the wall first
blaze motto anything for the fans you
got that right
interesting do i have a flashlight
you do
uh but apparently this is well lit
enough that nate doesn't feel like he
needs to use it oh he'll do it
automatically good
oh i see a winch opportunity
all right let's see here so let's go
back
raid that tomb
oh we're gonna be raiding it that's what
i say by the way um to myself on a date
raid that tomb
yeah that's okay it might be creepy
nope nothing i just need this winch real
quick you guys stay here they want you
to be an unlockable character don't
that's all that does is just read jane
austen
books in the back of that thing
your mo jane austen read it yeah but the
other day louis ck was on he was talking
about how he read pride and prejudice
and i was like beth was like oh my be
still my heart
it's required reading yeah you got to be
jane austen you got to
here we go wells have dead bodies now
someone said not water filled with dead
body
best kind of wells
first oh i'm gonna
uh get away from this thing it's about
to fall
i like that
oh
definitely a load-bearing pillar
oh
oh there we go
ooh interesting interest look right this
is where i fall
can i
oh man can you unlock mr darcy this is
such a such a good workout
oh this is cool so we can inspect right
yeah which
which idols you have which uh treasures
you found or pokemon as we were saying
yeah it is
jugglypuff or whatever you want to call
it this is the john goodman at mardi
gras uh
having a good time there look at those
he's actually at coachella too yeah yeah
yeah
he's like coachella pants
pajamas there yeah definitely
what do we just get we just got a pewter
letter cylinder uh-huh this is how i
send beth all my emails i just hand them
i print them out i send them to her in a
computer thing i read them that's right
never you never read anything let's get
in there that's awesome
dope all right
i don't think we need oh boy you got it
yeah oh yeah oh man perfect fingers of
steel great finger strength it's all
that rock climbing at the crunch gym
this game is fondre
oh man look at me
boom sauce
there are no holograms i'm sorry
no anime holograms or any of that
oh how uh big hit andy how long is the
game in hours if you it's not officially
oh it's not officially but it is because
of the wide linear nature of it it can
be really long if you wanted to yeah i
would say we are on our way to a very
long playthrough right now
thousands of hours spent
if you spend a lot of time jumping off
cliffs
the world is your oyster it's true are
you including this how many selfies i'm
going to take or and you know by the way
in multiplayer there are all these
taunts you do so you kind of knock
somebody out oh that's awesome you can
do kind of a dance move or something and
there's a selfie
you pull out a cell phone you kind of
take a picture with them
it's pretty funny that's funny
can you uh can i get out of the jeep
slide down a mud slope and have your
allies slide with me sure the next time
i see a mud slope
i don't know if you guys saw before but
i just love like the slipping animation
all this oh god really
dude you're good i'm actually trying to
drive now i'm not trying to drive like
an a-hole
i'm actually doing my best
the game is endless with photo
customization especially the way i play
it baby
the game that never ends that's what i
say on dates
exactly this game never ends this is a
real like date yes advice this is
it all relates back baby i love slips
you guys know i love slips
yeah we're only playing for 20 more
minutes so get in your questions now for
jimmy assistant editor at naughty dog
this game comes out midnight on the east
coast tonight at nine
pacific
uh whoever was asking it is it is a
linear campaign
it's still a very tight pace to the
story
you just have moments where you can kind
of wander and do your thing yeah you
just opened up the world
which is cool
yeah it's still classic uncharted
there's still a great storyline all the
way through
and the pacing is
oh man
jesus
oh someone is asking
is there a spot to post and view other
people's
um i photos we'll probably have like an
official hashtag that you can do um but
i would i would look into that maybe a
playstation blog post would have
something about that
i do also know they're setting something
up for multiplayer so if you have an
awesome play oh no
yes
you're live oh man all right
son of a winches oh man i love how i
almost i saved it and then just
oh it doesn't kill he makes you stronger
right that's true
but it also kills you
eventually you're dead
uh oh chili fall says without any
spoilers other easter eggs throughout
the game yeah awesome definitely and
that's why it's probably better to play
all of the uncharteds right yeah you
will get a lot of the stuff and you'll
get a lot of inside jokes from past 90
dog games as well
so this is another oh i love it the guys
are taking selfies over there
all right
i'll see this is why that's the rope
we'll see i wanted to get the sniper
right sniper rifle beth was like no no
just go you're fine with the ak i'm like
no dude i want the sniper rifle listen i
always say fine with the ak that's my
like that's your thing i was like ak
let's mark these goons
i know this is a bad idea you should go
up man i just feel like i just let me
just try killing them all by running
let's do it i just all right here we go
just just keep moving good
don't hit walls
ah man come on
that damn it no you're over nope nope
nope hey
oh i missed him now i miss somebody oh
look at that i can't stop running into
things except when i'm trying to hit a
guy hold on just let me just try one
more time
uh go tigers asked how this looks so
howdy fellas oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah i'm doing it jump out
get out get out let's go let's go cover
cover cover
oh
i love like i'm hiding right here
[Laughter]
oh yeah so go tigers it's really nothing
secret it's just a ton of work everybody
on the team is just super passionate
about games and they want things to be
as good as they can so they go out of
their way like any time they're like oh
this could be slightly better they just
do it it's insane never go into a
firefight with blay well now you guys
know all those fire fights uh
invitations i keep getting on facebook
i know i decline them
all right what should we do here i think
maybe yeah i mean you can sneak
you're doing good
uh alfizzle music uh there are a couple
things i feel like got close to
perfection on this one i i actually
think the gun play is really amazing in
this game
uh
i have to say that the handheld combat
is really and the hand-to-hand combat's
amazing it's super fun
and they'll just self-take comfort and
errands behind the wheel
oh here we go we're going up the back
side ah spoon editing a trailer takes a
really long time um
i think
i think we went through 76 versions wow
first story trailer oh my god that's
crazy
and that was just like different
versions then we had like four
slight things that we changed per
version
there you go oh yeah
oh
sleep sleep
oh we got an uzi a little rope oh do it
jump rope and then hit square on this
dude do it
i believe in you it's square
boom
wait what's a pair of 45 ah that's ammo
for your pistol oh perfect
oh man that was awesome
that's like a tarzan like hashtag tarzan
slam
there's other boy can i drop yeah you
can drop on them hit square eat them
that was awesome oh wait here we go oh
yeah do you remember when you shot me in
my other life now he sees you
you got it
there you go there we go right in the
bulletproof vest oh wait there's other d
oh whoops oh you can start chucking
grenades at this point too
wait where's it there's another oh
oh yeah yes
dude i love the hand-to-hand combat
you did it look at you oh man
and again
if i can kill dudes
anybody can because anyone can kill
dudes
exactly ooh
great question reptar knob uh who's your
favorite protagonist from all the uh oh
they're not adopted you know what i am
on team sully
really i love sully yeah yeah he's the
old curmudgeon it's pretty funny because
when we were making these trailers joe
the other editor yeah is always like
sully can't jump on ropes whenever we're
doing multiplayer he's like he's an old
man
he's incapable
and i always want to see sully just
doing batteries yeah
absolutely man he got it like hashtag
it's uh team sully yeah
exactly
that's true there are some guys like old
dudes who are rich yeah you gotta look
at harrison ford man yeah that's what
i'm saying guy just i like harrison ford
was there a story where he just crashed
like arie crash landed a plane on like a
golf course it was fine in santa monica
yeah yeah like learning a lot of offices
yeah was that true yeah that's it was
like a couple miles away dude that's
like nathan drake in real life
oh my god this might be too much making
in the sausage but your tool you're
talking about yeah i've seen this one i
probably shouldn't specify what software
i use i don't know but you're on the
right track for sure yeah a lot a lot of
uh
a lot of instagram audience a lot of
apps i edit on instagram yeah google
google maps i got it on instagram there
is a lot of debug stuff too so you can
use a kit like what we're playing on
actually to go in and change things in
software new team coco slogan if i can
kill dudes anyone can kill them
that is true if i can drive a jeep
anybody can
that's every other old dude crashing
into golf courses
chuck norris yeah there's definitely
some chuck norris and nathan drake i'd
say yeah i would definitely say so all
right here we go
all right here we are almost at the
smoke
man this game is awesome
and there will be dlc for this game
right mm-hmm yeah that's announced this
story dlc
there are two multiplayers
don't worry about it fellas i got us oh
i said don't worry about it
oh geez
[Music]
yeah i definitely hope i nathan got the
uh
insurance for this because i do not
just i like to make a 16 point turn
that's me in the parking garage
yeah exactly
oh dude the rocks oh that's great
there's no shortage of vistas
well that's that's what you want you
want oh i love that power move right
over sully
uh single-player dlc yeah that's awesome
by the way i'm always amazed like in
games and in real life like because
these things these kinds of things exist
in real life they had to haul all the
bricks and stone up there to make it
yeah and these are pirates that is
insane they are very organized pirates
paint the ass
is their character customization can i
make nathan have long hair there isn't
like
character customization what's more like
costumes yeah you can unlock um and then
you can play through the whole game in
different costumes yeah
i love it
oh this is kind of this is an
existential question from michael does
it feel empty when you finish it you
worked everything
yes i feel like it's got to feel like
i've kind of experienced this a little
bit like where like we went on tour with
conan and when it was done
you're really excited because you did
something really great yeah but it's
also like that's what you've been doing
for a long time so there is like you
feel like oh man yeah it's it's kind of
crazy there's a phrase that some of my
friends and i use called burning up on
reentry like you were in space
and you come down and it's a little too
fast yeah you're just
kind of burning up there's a little bit
of a postpartum depression for sure but
also a lot like you are like putting
something amazing you want water yeah i
think i just there is something oh i got
it there is something really cool
because you are putting something out in
the world that then other people you
finally get to show something that's
been so rewarding this week especially a
lot of stuff's coming out it's on
twitter you're seeing everybody react
the reviews were amazing yeah yeah just
totally exhilarating yeah absolutely
absolutely
uh oh yeah somebody's saying i love the
detail of how sam looks over the cliff
that's awesome he's also got a very
casual stance
look how catchy he is
i feel like a peter sarsgaard thing yeah
hashtag cash
let's go find this thing
you bet
pontiac what do you think about the way
how he puts his hand on the wall when he
runs actually don't you think it's
pretty germ threatening
we're learning a lot about you pontiac
gta building up uh tolerances exactly so
like two germs exactly
i did have a chemistry teacher who uh
took his hand like one of the first days
in class and put it across the desk and
licked it it was like i'm building up my
immunities and we were like
but thinking about it you probably ever
take a sick day
no bam never did he was also the swim
coach it was like this big like
come back with the kids days long i was
like oh all right high schools schools
are probably pretty uh immune building
too huh yeah emotionally too exactly
yeah exactly smooth jazz wine tasting
hashtag cash sam baby
so
how are you doing yeah still in one
piece
i appreciate you coming along for the
ride
dude sully is ripped
he's a ladies man
no problem
hell i'd be lying if i said i wasn't
enjoying myself
push him off the cliff airline
i'm not pushing him off the cliff
crazy you guys are getting psychotic
[Laughter]
you i didn't have to tell that story no
i did have to tell that story
uh al fizzl i would say my favorite
character in all naughty dog games is
probably joel from the last of us that's
great
troy baker sam in this one troy baker
guys together again great looking man oh
i can go oh i can climb up on this
that's cool
if i can get all the way to the top oh
look at those eagles
let's see if i can go over here
that's another thing that has been
innovated pretty well in this game is
that the climbing is a lot more
dynamic kind of reach around yeah you do
oh this is cool oh i can't get to the
top there's a little treasure oh
where's the treasure right there
oh there we go
see now we're talking good oh this is
great
oh now this is a selfie baby
photo dude this is the cover of my album
human reflections oh look at this eagles
oh this is great this is photo mode
this is definitely my tinder profile pic
and i mean in real life not nathan drake
and people are like you look just like
nathan drake you're in a yeah it's like
a video game
like if we had one of those facial
recognition apps and we pointed it at
this
it would think it was you zero matches
yes exactly let's see here i want to get
rid of this thing though
hold on wait no the frame here we go
oh yeah nope what's the best
can you guys please do a dlc
with an album cover like a like a like a
cd yeah or like a vinyl album cover look
at this that's great this is the sort of
thing that happens internally at naughty
dog
something kind of funny will happen and
we'll email it to everybody in the
office
as an album cover or whatever i love
that that's awesome
nate drake nest raider
well we have a dynamic cloud dlc oh yeah
the clouds do the clouds do move though
check that out
that's awesome
cloud editor
the uh hashtag on top of the world dudes
uh does dial do dialogue choices impact
the story
they do oh wow but it is still a linear
narrative so but that's cool that um
there you go that's your treasure give
me that treasure give me that oh god
oops
you lived definitely
definitely got a scratch or two you got
some shin splints yeah
machine split
yeah there we go i'm getting good at
jumping into a dude i'm better at
jumping into the jeep than actually
driving the jeep
there we go all right let's see where's
that other tower it was like oh it's
over this way
oh ah sorry sorry guys one second
you got a can to punch i got a karen to
put all right yep yep don't worry guys
just
text
yeah
it just
sounds weird
that's my favorite thing by the way
i want somebody to make a vine of that
just like
squad goals game is beautiful it is it
is beautiful
he's going to crash it off the cliff oh
i kind of want to
should we i feel like we should get to
the other tower we're only playing for
six more minutes so i do want to see
what this other team is actually
yeah this is going to be another combat
section so boy you'll get to see some
more fighting whoever was just asking
for that
all right well
let's
get
back up a little bit
no not all the way ah sam we don't need
to look back all right trust me man i
got this
i got this bro
[Music]
here we got here first oh so
check the place out and keep moving oh
outrage
medieval yeah
well you don't put up a drawbridge
unless you're trying to keep people out
no wise words somebody's been watching
game of thrones sully
all right so let's see here speaking of
which have you guys i haven't seen last
night's
no comment though
i heard i saw tumblr ruins everything
for me so i already saw what happened
yeah on tumblr which was like crazy yeah
that's some dark stuff there's some
there's some cool stuff yeah some dark
stuff yeah that's for
is huge like a time this is just a
question i have like
it's just like 2006 like is there like
this is now oh
no okay yeah
it's interesting
i was just thinking of like maybe they
do watch game of thrones like they could
don't trust the bridges in this game
yeah no kidding never trust the bridge
never trust a hashtag never trust a
bridge
although that did pretty well i mean all
this wood sitting out here exposed like
this it's gonna rot guys pirate wood
this is water pirate wood
and now that you guys are gonna turn
pirate wood into something dirty i know
you yeah you saw it say pirate wood and
think nothing will happen you can't just
you can't just can't stand bandy
[Laughter]
is this time before or after the
uncharted trilogy i think it takes place
after it's after
yeah um let's see i saw a line going oh
here it is i just gotta climb up more
what do i get let's see let's try and
color in
oh here we go i think up this way might
be the way
that is the other thing that's fun about
this is you can find multiple ways out
places it's not so just one oh that's
cool yeah
oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh
i said fingers of steel again
yarg i woke up with me all right i'm not
even gonna fish that's it i don't get it
red wedding is spoiled for me but
i mean also i will say like the thing
about game of thrones is it's also in
the books but i guess they're changing
some stuff right they're past the books
now they're past the books
did you read game of thrones too
all right sorry all right that's fine
wow did you read it yeah oh my god to be
that guy yeah i love it i love it
all right let's see here how do we i
feel like i can get up here oh yeah you
just gotta find a way around
here maybe this one
is that the way try it let's see what's
up this is what wide linear is all about
i love it
nope i got no
yeah try going over that wall see what's
a little bit let's see what's happening
have a great day thanks mostly you too
i can't crawl up the side of that can i
no
i would look for handholds stuff like
the
the pirate would the pirate wouldn't say
pirate would
nobody read the books
[Laughter]
ah i see where you should go i'm gonna
give you a hint yes all right jump over
this wall oh wait did you see that oh
it's right there oh i'm an idiot oh
jesus
the ladder
i mean the place all right the only
place i wasn't looking oh no nathan no
dude what are you doing bro all right i
got this
[Music]
so shoreline shoreline to the bad guys
basically they are yeah they're private
contractors and they're run by someone
named nadine ross
he's one of our antagonists and so we're
trying
they're they're trying to chase us to
the or we're trying to get to the
treasure before they are
yeah
all right i see all right let's go over
this way
you're welcome for the sneak peek thank
you for naughty dog thank you to naughty
dog for uh
giving us the showing off his acrobatics
it's just you know what i'm trying to do
i'm trying to make my forearms swell up
you know to get a good photo
no there we go
there you go there we go baby get up
monkey man all right let's see here
yeah i would hop over
there you go
where are we at here pretty close over
here
oh so close
never trust pirate wood guys never trust
it
there's another eagle hey guys
this is a place is lousy aren't you
supposed to be endangered this is where
they're all hanging out they're not in
danger there's chilling
just waiting for
album covers to happen i know exactly
[Music]
oh and he's going to be ripped when he
gets up
yeah
i should be getting this tomorrow i
booked the weekend to binge this yeah no
kidding you're going to want to take
some time off work
i'm sure naughty dog can't tell you that
you should call in sick from work but i
can i'm telling you you should
call in sick i got a bad case of the
drakes
a little bit of a puzzle aspect to this
i love this i love a good puzzle
oh man should i try the grenade thing
again you could try it i kind of want to
the sweet explosion but on the other
hand i know it's going to end me dying
i love it
nathan drake gets tetanus and dies in
horrible pain what if that's one of the
alternate endings
it's weird
that's awful
oh man all right it's 1 30 we have to
end i might try doing i really want to
get the explosion thing is that all
right if we oh look he's just
see it's all that climbing was yeah he's
just stretching his muscles that's crazy
i love that oh this is good yeah there's
a hint oh this is awesome
i love this all right you already knew
that i know i know
there we go
i you know what i'm gonna i'll try the
jump from up i'm gonna try the jump from
up there because i think it'll be a
better oh dude we'll jump off into the
waterfall this will be different
oh i slipped on the wood that's crazy
this is me at my job at kmart
i'm trying to get the dumpster out at
the end of the night like
all this garbage
is awesome
that's crazy like slipped on he slips on
wood
there you go minimum wage job puzzle
experience i'm just saying kmart was a
good job but the dumpster thing killed
me all right
todd my former manager
at kmart you know what i'm talking about
he's with me on that
all right i think up here
you got it do the slippety slip slop all
right now
a normal person this is in the game this
is where you would do the thing with the
winch but we were out of time so i just
want to try doing a uh
a grenade explosion jump off into
i think we could do it this thing's
totally gonna end with me dying this is
such a bad idea
you know i'll just put down the drawback
first
just because i know people it's gonna be
unsatisfying for people i can actually
i'll tell you a little spoiler all right
that'll start a fight okay let's hear
that there will be a bunch of people
that attack oh is that true oh man all
right well then we'll end with killing
yeah
instead of jumping i'll do the jump in
my private life or when we play this
game so this this multi-tapping is
another thing we have accessibility
options for by the way oh okay good
multitap oh yeah you can hold it oh good
oh perfect that's not i was doing that
for comedic effect of course
the warning shots but i'm gonna yell as
loud as i possibly can
all right well
oh i love it when bad guys taught me
because then when i murder them it's so
much better
oh yeah i'm definitely
oh wait i want to wait till dude
over there and rope them oh there's a
whole bunch oh yeah wait can i rope
those jeans yeah do it
[Applause]
swing over and hit square yo god he's
totally gonna see me no no no i'm just
hanging meat square square square no
no all right
old-fashioned way
oh that's awesome
switch weapons
oh god this is
oh my god this is a mess
oh jeez
i just want to oh dude yes this one
oh then sully yeah silly helping me out
helping your boy out
let's find some cover
whoa
we're flying now man
[Music]
don't take the sniper rifle says bats
you won't need take the ak
great idea beth
notice too that this
this wood it's not helping me
it's not eventually almost everything
you hide behind breaks really yeah oh
that's cool i mean horrifying it's hard
for me but really cool oh wait here we
go there's your sniper rifle give me
give me give me give me give me there
you go all right all right all right all
right all right
all right
this dude get him
damn it
oh my god it is breaking apart it's oh i
got shot to the thing
damn okay do you mind can i just do you
mind if i just kill these guys before we
end let's do it all right let's do it
let's do it all right here we go here we
go
don't take the sniper rifle you'll be
totally fine all right you know what i
think i got a little cutesy with the
thing and i'm going to do it again
you got to get cutesy behind you yes
there is that action exactly agent sully
here we go
i think the problem was
there goes
yeah swing that way and squared oh nope
oh he's not he's not that's all right
you're still
oh yeah
flank me will you oh very nice
that's another fun thing you always pull
them into the grass you're near grass
awesome
oh jeez
let's get him get him oh no click
yes yes yes
still stealthy up the stairs up the
stairs all right here we go i lost track
of the other dude
squad goals
oh there you could just shoot that
barrel right here
love
that i
[Music]
all right all right
i got it i got it i gotta do it
i gotta do it
get it oh
you know what you're right
yikes
let's not go out that way
that's a terrible idea oh you're dead
come here
another one oh
bro
nice
where are we at where are we at there's
one
there's a guy you're right
could definitely use
i love that you're all melee oh dude oh
it's so great it's so cinematic yeah
yeah that's another thing that they just
put a ton of animation work into there
are like 20 ways to punch someone in
this game and i'm going to see them all
today
it is really cool
there we go oh jesus
grenades dude r1 what are my grenades r1
oh jesus no
throw him that way
oh wait i'm still alive he's still alive
oh my god what was that the truck blew
up
oh
now you're dead super dead
steel fist for the win
i'm gonna host you guys thank you mma
fighter okay here we go
here we go we're actually eight everyone
is saying hopefully we beat this level
before the stream ends we will we will
that was a record we have to we have to
oh yes exactly
exactly that was like a hope everyone
just started it was a long story
but i'm glad everyone remembered yes
exactly we went through together
whoops
i'm gonna dodge
i'm not gonna
there you go
got that
[Music]
the barrel
yes
i love all the wood that splinters is
awesome
this is this is why we have hashtag
piratewood yeah seriously
[Music]
oh get up on the thing dude
[Music]
team sully
[Music]
this way
yeah let's go let's go
take a quick second wipe my brow
it looks like oh god this guy is
terrible playing this game here we go
here we go here we go
oh come on up here pal
yeah why don't you try to find me
now you might notice you you re-entered
stealth so when you're oh yeah now
they're looking for you again you can
keep
re-hiding if you need to get him sully
[Music]
i broke i broke the wood with his neck
that's harsh
let's see
all right how do we feel about a little
if you aim and then throw it you can
throw it farther too oh really
there you go oh wow great
that's a pro tip from jimmy that's nice
oh nice that's great look at the smoke
yeah isn't that amazing our particle
guys are ridiculous the whole team is
oh
love them barrels
jesus god
goodness
gracious
[Music]
oh that was something really bad
that was something really bad
oh my god if you get him you can have an
rpg though
it might be worth it
you know what i should have done i
should have marked these guys that was
stupid
[Music]
very nice oh there's a grenade launcher
oh no
all right last try last try this is it
this is it last try here's what we're
going to do we're going to mark them
we're going to mark them
we're going to learn from our mistakes
that's awesome
okay here we go here we go
[Music]
don't do it like me kids remember always
mark your enemies
this dude wants to get up here huh
nice sully
team sully team sully always
this guy's a sniper rifle damn it
there are a lot of guys i will say uh
you guys didn't skimp on the action in
this game
and what's nice is a lot of times people
were saying that the combat in previous
games were a little bit too tight
quartered and in this game obviously you
can do it 100 different ways totally
all right
nice let's get down let's get down to
the mix
let's mix it up
i think there was an exploding barrel up
there
oh whoops
oh that's perfect
juice
oh that's a cliff let's not run that
let's not run that way
really grenade god
[Music]
oh that's a nice grenade i think he got
him
nope didn't get him you didn't get him
too soon spoke too soon
[Music]
ah i'm getting shot at
it's a dude right there
oh triangle there you go look at that
teamwork that's great
[Music]
oh
double teamed him
here we go here we go
all right all right all right all right
let's regroup let's regroup where that
i might i might have got those guys up
top actually yeah you might have
here we go
[Music]
i think there's only two guys left
all it takes is one
all right here we go
um
so now you're back in stealth oh awesome
oh that's great
i love that that's extremely cool right
yeah so you can really
there are a lot of encounters in this
game that you can do exclusively in
stealth you can never break out of cover
you don't even have to shoot for a bunch
of these if i was better i could have
done this and stuff
very challenging yeah it's cool too
because you'll hear these guys have
conversations that you wouldn't have
heard otherwise they're just like
talking to each other
about previous missions they've been on
whatever there's a lot of dialogue
that's awesome
always mark your enemies kids remember
that there we go here we go
there you go
this is a good review of the game the
fact that you can't stop playing
i just kicked the dude off the thing
that was great
wow awesome holy moses ready to go that
was great well my god jimmy thank you
for coming once again jimmy myers let's
hear it
naughty dog
the game is uncharted 4. thief's end it
is out tonight midnight on the east
coast nine pacific time uh on the west
coast and thank you guys for showing up
this game is incredible uh and we'll be
playing this game quite a bit goodness
gracious thank you guys for showing up
as always i love it uh jen michael eor
slammy slammy jams all right thank you
guys this has been a super fun and
always remember you can watch us at
teamcoco.com
uh streamcocoa see you guys next week
bye
you